[Musique]
demain
ça donne
je pensais pas que ça allait être à
100 tout coeur qu'il ya deux jours je
perds du temps et
et vous payez ensemble j'ai vu pour
cousin - très proche
il y rester deux ou trois jours coucher
chez lui puis en soirée j'ai vu les
pompiers tout ça sans intervenir ça fait
des classements la tête mais pourquoi
parce que c'est pas des miellés quand
même assez
délicate et puis dur parce que quand on
voit la situation de la martinique on se
dit
nous sommes
oui oui mais les personnes qui se
présentent ont tous aujourd'hui dans
leur entourage quelqu'un d'hospitaliser
deux décédés ou deux souffrent
je n'y crois pas
non
parce que j'ai deux enfants qu'ils ont
eus clients en ce moment maladie
donc vu mon âge le dimanche
je l'essaie quand même entre guillemets
si ça peut se faire se faire au 2e